however to say that this is now a UK
government and a prime minister without
a shred of credibility is an
understatement indeed it is perhaps a
sign of how badly broken UK politics is
that the prime minister's resignation
has not already been tendered I also
reflect as first Minister that if I had
given into demands made by Tories and
indeed some commentators on the day of
the mini budget to match the UK
government's tax plans I too today would
be dealing with something of a financial
disaster it should I think be a relief
to everyone across Scotland that the
Scottish government did not act so
rashly it will also be galling I think
that the one measure that the Prime
Minister has repeatedly cited to
effectively justify the market turmoil
of recent weeks the energy price cap has
also now been curtailed leaving many
people and possibly many businesses
without the support with energy bills
that they were before today expecting
there's no doubt this is a
self-inflicted crisis for is trust and
it is humiliating in a quite
unprecedented way in terms of the climb
down I think the sooner this prime
minister and indeed this entire
government departs office the better
that will be for everyone
let me turn now to something that I hope
is more optimistic in laying out an
alternative for Scotland now I have a
lot of detail that I want to cover today
so I would ask people particularly the
journalists in the room to bear with me
once I have finished speaking however I
will give every journalist in the room
who wants to at the opportunity to ask a
question
um in today's paper we make the economic
case for Independence fundamentally we
argue in this paper that a stronger
fairer more sustainable economy is more
possible for Scotland with Independence
than it ever will be with continued
Westminster control
by combining Scotland's many economic
strengths and abundant resources
particularly our vast renewable energy
potential with the policy levers that
come with Independence an economic model
built on social partnership and good
stable governance we can build a
well-being economy that works for all
we also address in this paper key
questions on currency fiscal
sustainability and trade and I'll see
more on these topics shortly
in 2014 the choice before the Scottish
people was framed by Westminster parties
as the strength and stability of the UK
on the one hand and the uncertainty of
Independence on the other the reality in
the years since has been very different
it is glaringly obvious now that the UK
does not offer economic strength and
stability or Financial Security on top
of an already crippling cost of living
crisis calamitous decisions in recent
weeks taken by a government Scotland did
not vote for have sent mortgage rates
through the roof and brought Pension
funds to the brink of collapse it is now
very clear that we also now face another
round of austerity cuts that will damage
our Public Services perhaps
existentially push more people into
poverty and further Shred the safety net
that is so essential to any decent
Society so so that is the so-called
certainty that continued Westminster
governance now offers us
and while recent events have brought
this into sharper Focus this is a crisis
long in the making and it is not a
temporary phenomenon the UK economy is
in long-term decline the UK economic
model is failing and failing badly the
facts speak for themselves the UK is
poorer than many of its International
competitors indeed as the first paper in
this series demonstrated it is
substantially poorer than independent
European countries comparable to
Scotland it has lower national income
per head wider inequality higher rates
of child and pension or poverty and
lower productivity
more and more the UK looks like an
outlier in economic policies performance
and social outcomes
brexit of course has turbocharged these
Trends over time and compared with EU
membership brexit will wipe billions of
pounds from the Scottish economy and the
tax revenues that support Public
Services yet inexplicably all the main
Westminster parties now back it there is
no route for Scotland as part of the UK
back to the EU or to the single Market
or Customs Union if we stay as we are as
part of the Westminster system the
outlook for Scotland is this austerity
low growth wages and living standards
stagnant at best high and growing
inequality Rising rates of poverty
economic damage reduced trade and
narrowed Horizons as a result of brexit
and all of it exacerbated by
increasingly dysfunctional Westminster
decision making
the price of this for people across
Scotland will be heavy
however I know that there are many
people who even though they agree with
that analysis still have big and fair
questions about independence questions
like why now in these tough times is a
stronger fatal economy really possible
with Independence what currency will we
use how will we deal with any debt and
deficit we inherit how can we protect
trade across the UK If we are back in
the EU this paper addresses these
questions openly and frankly first why
now there is an understandable human
instinct to hunker down in the face of a
storm and hope for camera times but for
the UK this is not just a passing storm
the UK economy is fundamentally on the
wrong path and there is no real
alternative on offer within the
Westminster system The Establishment
consensus on brexit despite the harm it
is causing illustrates that for Scotland
not being independent means we have been
dragged down the wrong path to a path
people here did not vote for
to build a more stable sustainable
economy with fairness and human
well-being at heart Independence is
essential and that's the fundamental
point we make in this paper Independence
is not an abstract argument separate
from people's daily lives it has at its
heart the ambition and crucially it
equips us with the essential tools to
build a fairer wealthier Greener happier
country I know however that it's not
enough to show that the UK economic
model is failing even though it
demonstrably is we must demonstrate the
independence offers a better alternative
now independence is not a medical cure
there are no guarantees of economic
success for any country for Scotland
like every other independent nation our
success will depend on the quality of
the decisions we take it will be hard
work but this paper sets out the reasons
for believing that we can succeed after
all we know that for other independent
countries of our size or smaller
Independence already works why would it
not for Scotland especially as we have
so many economic strengths that many of
them don't vast renewable energy
resources internationally competitive
industries from food and drink to
technology from tourism to life sciences
and the space sector more world-class
universities proportionately than almost
any other country on the planet a
creative skilled and highly educated
population the policy tools we get with
Independence will allow us to make the
most of the these strengths as in any
democracy different governments will
meet different choices but in this paper
we set out some of the opportunities
that the economic powers of Independence
will open for us for example with powers
to reform the energy Market we could
ensure that our renewable resources
deliver security of supply and lower
costs while also tackling the climate
emergency we could ensure fairer work
european-style labor market policies in
place of Westminster anti-trade Union
laws can bring government business and
trade unions together in a social
partnership underpinned by greater
worker involvement and stronger
collective bargaining this is the kind
of approach increasingly championed by
organizations like the oecd as the best
route to high wage productive economies
that are sustainable and more inclusive
with employment law Powers we could do
more to tackle the gender pay Gap and
age discrimination ensuring for example
that young people receive the same
minimum wage rate as everyone else it is
an approach based on human well-being
lifting people up so that they can
contribute fully not waiting for wealth
to trickle down while the inequality Gap
grows
with Independence we can rejoin the EU
and be back inside the world's biggest
trading block as an EU member state in
our own right we would for the first
time be in a position not just to
benefit from EU trade deals but help
shape them we would have an immigration
policy tailored to our needs and we
would have the stability of knowing that
the government's making the decisions
that shape our economy have actually
been elected by us
these are just some of the opportunities
Independence would open up
another overarching question I know
people have though is this one how do we
get from here to there in this paper we
take that head-on
as the events of recent weeks have
indeed underlined whether we like it or
not fiscal credibility and Market
confidence are essential to the
well-being and living standards of all
of us that understanding is Central to
the approaches we set out firstly we
describe in this paper the new financial
institutions that will be required to
help ensure such credibility and
confidence on that though it's worth
noting that we are so much more advanced
than in 2014. back then Scotland didn't
have its own tax or social security
agencies we do now indeed there have
surely been few if any nations in
history better prepared for Independence
than we are
to add to those institutions already in
place we would create an independent
Scottish Central Bank a debt management
office and significantly strengthened
the Scottish fiscal commission so that
it effectively replicates the office for
Budget responsibility these institutions
would operate independently of
government and help ensure Financial
stability transparent economic
forecasting and performance monitoring
and a responsible purposeful and
efficient use of borrowing powers
second we address the issue of currency
we confirm that the policy of the
Scottish government is to establish a
Scottish pound we would seek to do this
as soon as practicable the precise
timing would be determined not by a
fixed timetable but by a set of
objective requirements and criteria
Guided by advice from the central bank
and subject to a decision by parliament
in the overall interest of the country
this paper sets out in detail a careful
and responsible phased approach as well
as the arrangements necessary to support
a new currency and in the shorter term
her continued use of Sterling the people
also sets out the approach we would take
to securing fiscal sustainability again
this recognizes the vital importance of
confidence and credibility in public
finances the deficit and debt and
independent Scotland will start out with
will be derived from and influenced by
the overall UK position in the case of
debt it will also be determined by
negotiations that follow a vote for
Independence as was established in 2014
Scotland would not have legal
responsibility for UK debt we do however
in my view be a moral responsibility in
light of that and indeed our desire for
strong future partnership between
Scottish and UK governments we would
seek a fair settlement on both debt and
assets
now given the turmoil engulfing the UK's
finances at this time it is not possible
to make an estimate of our starting
fiscal position though the ifs has
suggested that in
2022-23 Scotland's deficit is likely to
be similar to or lower than the uks we
do confirm that we would set clear
fiscal rules to put and keep public
finances on a sustainable path we would
intend these to align with the broad
principles of the European growth and
stability pact which is currently being
reformed we intend to have fiscal rules
that keep day-to-day spending within
sustainable limits and debt on a
sustainable path but still permit
governments to properly support public
services and borrow to invest
we reject austerity as both morally
wrong and economically counterproductive
further we do not accept that austerity
is necessary in a country as wealthy as
Scotland and without abundance of
resources it is ultimately the creation
of a sustainable inclusive economy that
delivers fiscal sustainability neither
austerity nor tax cuts for the
wealthiest will deliver that it will
come instead from investment in people
and infrastructure that is why we
propose in this paper the building a new
Scotland fund oil and gas is a declining
asset and Our obligation to the planet
means that we must move away from fossil
fuels as quickly as possible boiling gas
can be switched off overnight so
Scotland could benefit from these
revenues for some time yet if we invest
remaining oil revenues and use our new
borrowing Powers responsibly and foreign
purpose we can invest up to 20 billion
pounds in the first decade of
Independence this investment will help
accelerate the transition to Net Zero
and transform communities and crucially
it will help kick-start the inclusive
growth that will help get our newly
independent nation on a fiscally
sustainable path while building the fair
Society we all want
lastly the paper considers the issue of
borders and trade although we will
publish a further paper later in this
series specifically on European Union
issues there are two important points to
underline at the outset firstly
Independence opens the door to Scotland
rejoining the EU and the single Market
that will allow us to grow and diversify
our trade in the way Ireland did after
joining the EU trade across the UK is
important but that must not be the limit
of our ambition not when we have a
market seven times the size of the UK on
our doorstep
second Scotland will remain in the
common travel area with the rest of the
UK and Ireland that means any talk of
passports to visit relatives in England
is utter nonsense free movement of
people across our Islands will continue
as before an independent Scotland though
back in the EU will also regain free
movement across 27 other countries
what breaks it does mean though when
Scotland returns to the EU is that
border Arrangements will be required to
ensure continued trade in goods and
services across the UK none of this none
of this is insurmountable but it does
require proper planning most of
Scotland's trade with the rest of the UK
is in services and we set out the
arrangements that will need to be in
place to ensure that continues as far as
manufactured goods are concerned the
things that actually physically cross
borders we actually export more to the
rest of the world than to the rest of
the UK nevertheless we set out here the
mechanisms by which necessary checks can
be carried out in a way that allows
smooth trade to continue it makes clear
that we would provide support to traders
to adapt it is important to note that
for the purposes of this paper we assume
that the UK EU relationship will be
governed in the longer term by the
current feed and cooperation agreement
however over time it is possible that
economic reality if not common sense
will lead the UK to Greater alignment
with the single market and to agreements
that reduce the requirement for checks
now in the time available to me today
and thank you for bearing with me I've
only been able to summarize this paper I
encourage everyone with an interest to
read it in full it can be accessed at
gov.com forward slash New Scotland
in the coming weeks and months we will
publish further papers on EU membership
energy pensions and social security for
example today though marks a milestone
in the conversation about how we can
build a better Scotland and that kind of
optimism I think is very necessary at
this time there can't be many if any who
look at Westminster right now and think
that this is as good as it gets but in
relation to an independent Scotland
people well we're going to step away
from Nicola sturgeon there she's setting
out the case for another referendum on
Scottish independence using brexit and
the current economic woes of the UK to
argue that this is the right time saying
that issues such as border Arrangements
across the UK are not unsurmountable and
that she talks about what is happening
in the Westminster Parliament that sign
of how broken how broken the system is
that the UK prime minister hasn't yet
resigned